"Uncatchable",
Alexandr Zhelanov
...
-Fabrice D'Almeida,
pourquoi jamais
nous ne pouvons parler
de l'Afrique sereinement ?
-Pour moi, c'est un gros problème
d'en parler sereinement
car ça rejoint l'histoire intime,
l'histoire familiale
donc c'est à chaque fois...
-Franco-béninoise dans votre cas.
-Exactement
et c'est une tension parce que,
comme j'ai un mouvement de vie...
On a vécu là-bas,
toute mon enfance est là-bas,
je reviens en France.
-Au Bénin.
-Voilà,
mon père reste là-bas,
donc y a un mélange de psychologie
et de, comment dirais-je,
de vie personnelle
et par ailleurs,
et ensuite,
toutes les thématiques politiques
des années 60-70,
qui ont été celles
de mon enfance,
qui en permanence me hantent
dans cette question
de : qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'être indépendant ?
-Vous êtes un enfant
de l'indépendance,
en fait.
-Pratiquement.
-Sans dévoiler de secret,
vous êtes né
en 1963 et le Bénin venait
d'arriver à l'indépendance.
-En 60, exactement,
comme toutes les colonies
subsahariennes françaises,
il gagne son indépendance,
je vis mes premières années là-bas
et ma mère y vit
et y est prof.
-Hélène D'Almeida, née Topor.
-Exactement.
Euh, tiens, ça va vous faire marrer,
c'était une communiste, au départ.
-Elle est communiste.
On voit votre père
et votre mère.
-Maman était membre du Parti
Communiste jusqu'en 56,
la même cellule
qu'Annie Kriegel,
que François Furet.
-Tous des historiens célèbres.
-Et tous après s'écartent du parti,
après 1956,
en se rendant compte
des crimes de Staline.
-Et elle rencontre votre père,
monsieur D'Almeida.
-Exactement
dans ces années-là,
elle passe l'agrégation,
elle rencontre mon père,
on sent qu'il va
y avoir les indépendances,
ils décident de vivre au Bénin
parce que mon père
est originaire du Bénin,
il a fait une partie
de ses études au Sénégal,
ensuite, il a fait son lycée
à Tours, en France,
avant de faire sa spécialisation
en agronomie à Paris.
Donc ils se rencontrent là
et à partir de là,
ma mère va se mettre à travailler
sur l'Afrique
et va essayer de tester
ses méthodes éducatives sur nous.
Donc j'ai pas eu une éducation
complètement africaine,
j'avais le droit aux coups
de ceinture de papa
de temps en temps
mais avec maman qui me disait :
"jamais un coup
ne viendra de moi".
-Un a parlé de l'histoire
et de l'Afrique,
c'est Nicolas Sarkozy
quand il est allé à Dakar,
juste après son élection,
en 2007.
Il fait une conférence
à l'université
Cheikh-Anta-Diop et là,
il dit que l'homme africain
n'est pas entré
dans l'histoire.
Vous, vous êtes historien,
vous êtes agrégé d'histoire,
qu'est-ce que le regard
d'un historien comme vous
peut avoir sur ce discours,
qui est évidemment
beaucoup plus argumenté
que ce que je viens de dire.
-C'est un discours
à côté de la plaque.
-On va l'écouter un petit peu.
-Allons-y !
-La visite qui a marqué
les esprits,
la voici,
c'était le 26 juillet 2007
et ce jour-là,
Nicolas Sarkozy déclenchait
la polémique avec cette phrase.
-Le drame de l'Afrique,
c'est que l'homme africain
n'est pas assez entré
dans l'histoire.
-"N'est pas assez entré
dans l'histoire".
-Mais le problème,
c'est comment on y entre.
Toute la question qui est posée ici,
c'est celle de la colonisation,
de l'entrée en contact
avec le monde occidental.
Cette colonisation,
c'est ce que nous avons
beaucoup de mal,
aujourd'hui, Français,
à comprendre, à admettre,
c'est ce mélange de brutalité,
de violence et, en même temps,
d'une autre partie de la population,
ce désir de rencontre,
d'échange et de partage,
on peut aller jusque-là.
-Les Occidentaux ?
-Oui, mais en même temps,
y a la brutalité
et la prise de ces territoires
se fait par la guerre.
Dans le cas du Bénin,
on l'a oublié,
mais y a une campagne militaire
menée par un corps
expéditionnaire français
qui va arriver là-bas,
qui va être emmenée par un colonel,
au début de la mission,
qui sera nommé général
pour la guerre qu'il a menée
et qui va détruire
le royaume du Dahomey,
qui était gouverné par Béhanzin,
et qui fait une guerre impitoyable.
Ils sont une supériorité en armement
et donc ils en profitent,
même si, la première bataille,
ils la perdent,
avec la charge phénoménale
d'un groupe de femmes soldats,
les amazones, voilà,
qui étaient l'objet d'admiration
et de recherches de ma mère.
-Et qui, effectivement,
votre mère a travaillé là-dessus,
on est à la fin du 19e siècle.
-Ouais, exactement, et c'est une...
Ca montre cette inégalité
dans la conquête, en fait,
cette inégalité dans la force
et qui fait que l'échange,
le commerce,
la prise des matières premières,
bah, se fait sous la contrainte
et sous la force.
-Quand vous étiez jeune élève,
dans ce qui était le Dahomey,
à l'époque, encore,
qui s'appelait le Dahomey,
le Bénin est arrivé plus tard,
est-ce que vous avez senti
ce rapport de force,
dans les années 60,
juste après l'indépendance ?
-Moi, je suis dans une école
africaine,
l'école Félicien Nadjo,
une école un peu expérimentale
où on envoyait les jeunes
instituteurs en formation,
on faisait chaque semaine
la levée des couleurs,
on chantait l'hymne national,
je l'ai encore en tête,
j'ai appris cet hymne du Dahomey
avant d'apprendre l'hymne français,
"La Marseillaise".
Et je l'avais
dans la tête et...
Y avait le côté,
dès qu'il y avait un Blanc,
c'était le yovo,
c'est comme ça qu'on l'appelait,
mais entre élèves,
y avait pas ça, en fait.
On jouait, en fait...
Ce qui est assez marrant,
c'est que c'est l'époque,
les années 60,
où y a les westerns
et donc tous les gamins,
dans la cour, on est obsédés
par les cow-boys, Indiens, shérifs,
donc ça et la conquête de la Lune,
faut pas l'oublier,
parce qu'il y a en 1969
cet événement qui,
et c'est là où les Africains
sont dans l'histoire,
ils suivent ça et ils sont
passionnées par ça.
-Vous avez écrit un livre,
"Et si on refaisait l'histoire ?"
avec Anthony Rowley,
qui malheureusement nous a quittés,
mais un fameux historien.
Vous n'avez pas l'impression
que, aujourd'hui,
sur l'Afrique, on refait l'histoire
et que certains veulent
la réécrire ?
-Y a une nécessité de la réécrire.
-Pourquoi ?
-Une bonne partie de l'histoire
a longtemps été écrite
par les vainqueurs,
par les dominants,
donc y avait la légitimation
des systèmes de domination.
Et au fond, en reprenant l'histoire,
en la reprenant par le bas...
-Ils ont été écrits
par les chasseurs,
comme dit
un proverbe africain,
justement.
-Exactement et donc heureusement,
y a maintenant,
notamment grâce à des femmes
comme Catherine Coquery-Vidrovitch,
comme ma mère,
y a eu une génération
de chercheurs africains qui ont pris
en charge leur propre sujet.
Je pense à un Béninois,
vous allez m'excuser d'être
obsessionnel de ce territoire,
y a des personnages extraordinaires,
dont Félix Iroko,
qui est un très grand historien.
Félix Iroko a commencé à faire
des histoires
des pratiques,
de l'environnement.
Il est le premier à avoir fait
une histoire des termitières
en Afrique, qui sont très anciennes,
donc il y a des strates
d'histoire à l'intérieur
pour reconstituer le climat,
les cultures.
Y a tout un modèle
intellectuel qui émerge
et c'est un des historiens
qui a repris cette histoire
de l'esclavage et de la traite
en Afrique en la regardant...
-Le Bénin était au coeur de ça.
-Oui, c'était l'ancienne
côte des esclaves,
y avait la côté de l'ivoire
et la côte des esclaves,
c'était le rivage du Bénin,
sur le golfe du Bénin.
Et donc ce territoire a eu aussi,
a fait aussi une partie
de sa fortune
et de sa puissance militaire
en vendant des escalves.
C'est comme ça que, aussi,
on peut reconstituer
l'histoire de ces Etats côtiers
qui étaient commerçants
mais qui avaient une prospérité
grâce à l'esclavage.
-Aujourd'hui, y a aussi
une tentation, avec la culture,
la cancel culture,
de réécrire aussi cette histoire
et de gommer, justement,
avec une vision morale,
tout ce qui a pu se passer
par un passé qui ne passe pas,
finalement.
-Je suis pas sûr que, en Afrique,
ce soit la cancel culture,
au contraire,
c'est plutôt la contest culture,
c'est-à-dire qu'on conteste
un certain état des choses,
une certaine vision du monde,
qui suppose que l'ordre démocratique
soit le même partout,
que les modèles d'échange
soient les mêmes partout.
-Ce qu'on appelle le panafricanisme,
qui a changé de visage ?
-Notamment,
mais au fond, c'est l'idée
de réfléchir à la domination,
et à la domination
et au rôle de dominant
d'élites africaines.
Donc d'où tenaient-elles
leur légitimité ?
Y a une génération qui est arrivée
parce qu'elle est arrivée
dans la lutte.
On a oublié,
mais les Houphouët-Boigny,
ils deviennent ministres
mais ils le deviennent en partant
d'une position, au départ,
opposée, adversaire,
concurrente.
-Ministre sous la IVe République,
en France,
et un peu au début de la Ve.
-Alors qu'il portait
un discours d'autonomie
puis un discours d'indépendance.
Donc c'est des mouvements
qui étaient très forts et eux,
ils ont la légitimité d'avoir gagné,
d'une certaine manière,
l'indépendance,
mais les générations après,
d'où tirent-elles
leur légitimité ?
De la force, du vote,
de la filiation ?
Tout ça pose beaucoup de problèmes
et explique cette culture
de la contestation
pour les gouvernants et pour ceux
qui, éventuellement,
jouent les marionnettistes derrière.
-Est-ce qu'il y a pas, justement,
une espèce de conflit générationnel
entre ceux qui,
d'une certaine façon,
ont participé à ces indépendances,
ont lutté pour l'indépendance,
mais se sont accommodés,
d'une certaine façon,
du passé colonial
et aujourd'hui, justement,
cette jeunesse africaine
qui est beaucoup plus virulente
et qui veut, justement,
eh bien couper les ponts,
d'une certaine façon,
avec la culture occidentale ?
-C'est hyper ambivalent
parce que le...
Enfin, je veux dire,
si on se promène
dans les rues de Lagos,
ou même dans les rues de villes
d'Etats plus développés
comme l'Afrique du Sud,
on a tous le rêve américain,
on a tous le rêve
de la vie belle, facile, etc.,
un rêve que l'enfant occidental
partage avec l'enfant africain.
Donc y a ce mythe,
y a cette idée aussi qu'on va
pouvoir aller dans ces pays-là
pour éventuellement
tenter sa chance et faire fortune.
Donc là-dessus,
y a toujours une très grande
attractivité.
En revanche,
là où y a une contestation,
c'est l'idée de dire
qu'il y a qu'un modèle
unique qui leur serait imposé.
C'est le reproche qu'on fait souvent
aux...
-Le modèle occidental.
-...qu'on fait souvent aux Français,
c'est de donner l'impression,
le discours de Nicolas Sarkozy
en est un peu l'indice,
qu'il y a qu'une manière
de se développer
et d'être
qui soit positive au monde.
Et c'est ça qui, souvent,
fait qu'ils cherchent
des alternatives,
d'autres groupes pour les aider,
jadis l'URSS,
aujourd'hui la Chine et la Russie,
parce qu'ils cherchent l'alternative
pour avoir leur propre
logique de développement,
leur propre logique de définition
de la légitimité
et de la culture, même.
-Y a une volonté de réappropriation
justement de son identité,
on le voit, d'ailleurs, avec,
aujourd'hui, la restitution
des oeuvres d'art, aussi,
de son identité, sa culture.
Et d'ailleurs,
le Bénin est
au premier chef concerné,
ça a fait pas mal de bruit,
y a eu la restitution
de ces statues,
qui paraissent petites
mais qui sont beaucoup plus grandes,
les statues d'Abomey,
qui était le royaume d'Abomey.
-C'est les statues des trois rois
qui se sont succédé,
Ghézo, Glélé et Abomey,
qui ont construit un vrai royaume,
une puissance militaire
et qui sont vaincus
et ces statues sont prises
dans le palais royal
d'Abomey par le général Doods,
qui les rapporte
en France comme trophée
de la victoire militaire.
Et c'est vrai qu'Emmanuel Macron
a pris la décision
de les rendre, de les restituer,
après le rapport
fait par deux personnalités
éminentes,
Sarr et Savoy, et au fond,
ça pose une question
parce que le Bénin actuel,
il a été en partie construit
par ceux qui étaient
pour la défaite du royaume d'Abomey.
A l'époque, les royaumes
de Ouidah et Porto-Novo sont plutôt
sous l'influence française
et donc opposés au royaume
d'Abomey qui essaie
de leur imposer
sa règle par la force.
En fait, aujourd'hui,
et notamment Porto-Novo
était concurrent
de ce royaume.
Donc c'est assez amusant de se dire
qu'on restitue ça à un Etat
qui prend comme identité
l'Etat qui s'est battu
et qui minorise,
enfin,
qui donne une position mineure,
en fait, à ceux qui étaient
j'allais dire les collabos.
Pour le coup,
j'en parle comme ça
parce que c'est ma famille.
Au fond, moi, j'appartiens
à un groupe très connu
des Africains,
qu'on appelle les Afro-Brésiliens,
des gens qui sont des descendants
soit d'esclaves
soit de personnes parties en traite,
comme on dit,
au Brésil,
qui sont là-bas devenus
libres et qui sont revenus
en portant les noms
de leurs anciens maîtres.
D'Almeida, mon nom,
c'est un nom qui vient du Brésil,
c'est un nom portugais.
Ma nationalité,
quand ma famille revient en Afrique,
elle est portugaise,
on revient avant
l'indépendance du Brésil,
donc on est portugais.
On s'inscrit à Porto-Novo
dans le fort portugais
et on est pour les Français
car on a une maison de commerce
et on veut que les Français gagnent
car, avec eux,
il y aura la tranquillité
et la sécurité pour le business.
Une partie de ma famille va être
secrétaire général du gouverneur
et mon oncle, Ignacio-Pinto,
va être dans le même parti
que Houphouët-Boigny,
sénateur sous la IVe République.
-Ce qui explique aussi
que la religion
du vaudou est partagée
aussi bien en Amérique latine,
notamment au Brésil,
et au Bénin car c'est vraiment
le pays d'Afrique où on cultive
ce culte du vaudou qui,
aujourd'hui,
est encore démultiplié
par rapport à ce qu'il était
par le passé.
C'est aussi une attraction
touristique.
-Ouais, bah après,
y a ceux qui y croient !
Quand on a vécu
quelques années là-bas,
on finit par avoir
une trouille bleue
de parler de ça
parce qu'il y a toujours
la menace du sorcier,
y a toujours
la menace de la...
de la... du sort
qui va être jeté à distance.
Mais, au fond,
quand on était en vacances,
dans les années 60,
on allait en Bourgogne,
dans le Morvan.
Et dans le Morvan, y avait encore
un peu cet esprit superstitieux
qu'une partie de campagnes
françaises "ont" gardé
et on guettait quand quelqu'un
vous faisait des cornes.
C'était pas si loin.
-Quand vous regardez
le continent africain,
qu'on regarde un peu la politique
qui se déroule aujourd'hui,
est-ce qu'il y a pas un recul
d'une démocratie qui commençait
à s'installer dans les années...
les années 90, les années 2000
et, aujourd'hui, on le voit,
à travers des coups d'Etat,
au Sahel, notamment,
au Mali, au Burkina Faso,
un recul de cette démocratie ?
-Moi, j'y vois justement
la preuve que l'Afrique
est dans l'histoire, vraiment,
parce que ce qui se passe,
en réalité,
est tout à fait parallèle
à ce qu'on voit en Amérique latine
avec la montée en puissance
d'un Bolsonaro,
avec ce qui a pu se passer
au Venezuela, aussi,
avec Chavez
et son successeur, Maduro,
on voit la même chose
aux Etats-Unis avec Trump,
où la question
de la pratique démocratique
est remise en cause,
et on le voit
en France où y a
le même débat sur...
-Tentation populiste.
-Oui et est-ce que nos institutions
sont encore bonnes,
est-ce qu'il faut les changer ?
Et donc les Africains
sont traversés
par les mêmes courants
ou situations,
d'autant plus qu'ils ont
une vigueur économique
qu'ils ont pas eue durant longtemps,
des taux de croissance
depuis les années 2000
qui sont extrêmement importants,
y a de la richesse,
des figures qui émergent.
Ce continent,
dans les années 60, n'avait pas
de vrais riches.
Les riches pour l'essentiel
étaient des Occidentaux.
Depuis les années 2000
et même dans les années 80,
on a de très grandes
fortunes africaines,
on a des milliardaires.
Aliko Dangote, au Nigeria,
c'est une figure
qui représente la même chose
que ce que peut représenter
un Bernard Arnault en France.
C'est la capacité que s'est donnée
ce continent d'organiser
lui-même son investissement.
C'est absolument crucial.
Et donc on remarque la même chose,
la même logique d'évolution
qu'en Europe ou aux Etats-Unis.
-Et il est d'ailleurs l'objet
de toutes les convoitises,
aujourd'hui, ce continent.
Les Britanniques,
les Français nostalgiques
de la grandeur d'antan
quand ils y étaient très influents,
mais les Chinois, les Russes,
les Turcs, les Israéliens,
les Iraniens...
-Qui remplacent les Libanais.
C'est le continent du 21e siècle ?
-Bah c'est le continent, en fait,
où y a besoin le plus d'équipements,
donc à la fois,
c'est un marché et,
par ailleurs,
c'est le continent qui a énormément
de ressources naturelles
qui semblent aux autres
plus accessibles et moins chères.
C'est pour ça qu'il se joue
aujourd'hui et, je pense,
dans les décennies qui viennent,
une lutte très virulente
pour à la fois tenir le marché
et tenir les matières premières.
C'est tout l'enjeu mais,
j'allais dire,
c'est un peu le drame
de l'Afrique :
ce continent est toujours
regardé comme une ressource.
Et je pense que,
ce qui change,
c'est que la montée
en puissance économique,
en en faisant un marché,
va obliger une partie
des acteurs économiques
à modifier leur attitude.
-Un Sénégalais qui enseigne
aux Etats-Unis,
Souleymane Bachir Diagne,
dit qu'il est grand temps,
qu'il est urgent que,
maintenant, on regarde
le monde depuis l'Afrique.
Ca veut dire quoi, ça ?
-Que, chaque fois,
il y a eu des polarités
dans l'histoire du monde
et que le regard universel a
toujours été à partir d'un centre.
-Parce que c'est aussi
un pape de l'universel.
-Voilà, mais c'est vrai que
le regard posé à partir de là,
c'est d'ailleurs très frappant
si on effectue des cartes,
on se rend compte
qu'on peut modifier
la centralité.
Vous vous souvenez,
les cartes qu'on avait, nous,
quand on était petits,
elles étaient toutes
centrées sur la France,
donc on avait l'impression
d'un monde organisé
à partir de nous,
les voies maritimes, ferrées...
A partir de l'Afrique,
on constate
qu'il y a d'incroyables routes
et chemins de commerce
et d'industrie
qui sont mis en place.
Donc effectivement,
je crois que décentrer ce regard
est absolument crucial
et ne pas seulement passer
d'un regard américain
pour en faire un regard chinois.
-Mais les routes dont vous parlez,
elles ressemblent aussi à des routes
de la tragédie, du tragique,
avec cet exil,
avec ces routes de migrations,
finalement, où on voit
ceux qui partent d'Afrique,
qui fuient la misère,
le réchauffement climatique.
-Et la politique aussi.
-La dictature.
Et, bien souvent,
c'est ceux qui peuvent
se le permettre,
qui sont éduqués,
qui sont riches, enfin,
qui sont riches,
qui ont les moyens de le faire.
C'est le drame de l'Afrique,
non, qu'elle se vide ?
-Oui, un drame ancien.
On a l'impression qu'on continue
aujourd'hui sous une autre forme
la ponction démographique
qu'on a effectuée sur ce continent
depuis le Moyen Age,
y a eu la traite musulmane,
ensuite la traite occidentale,
et en fait, à chaque fois,
le dynamisme démographique est pris.
Mais je crois que, là,
on est dans autre chose.
Ce que ça pose comme question,
c'est à la fois
la question que ça pose chez nous,
en France, et en Europe,
plus largement, qui est celle
de l'homogénéité culturelle
et tout le débat qu'on a
et qui est lacérant,
dans notre société
depuis les années 80
avec la montée du Front
puis du Rassemblement National,
mais ça pose la même question
en Afrique :
l'intolérance qu'on a par rapport
à certains groupes ethniques.
On regarde souvent les Etats
africains comme des Etats
donnés avec la même logique
d'homogénéité que la nôtre,
mais à l'intérieur,
y a une ethnicité
extrêmement puissante et vigoureuse,
qui explique parfois
des tensions internes très violentes
et donc des poursuites,
des rejets et nécessités de fuites.
Ce qui me frappe,
c'est pour ça que cette culture
universelle est importante,
c'est d'essayer justement d'avoir
cet universalisme de l'humanité
pour pouvoir cohabiter
et pas seulement,
j'allais dire,
cette exigence obsessionnelle
de la nationalité ou de l'ethnicité
qui finit par construire du conflit,
du massacre et de la liquidation.
-Vous êtes particulièrement exposé
à ça parce que vous êtes métis
et c'est dur de parfois...
Alors, en Afrique,
on va vous dire que
vous n'êtes pas africain
et, en France, on vous dit
que vous n'êtes pas français.
-Moi, j'ai une chance inouïe,
je veux dire,
je vis dans un pays
qui m'a accepté,
qui m'a accepté
et m'a donné des choses...
-Vous parlez de la France ?
-Bah oui,
qui sont inimaginables.
Ce pays m'a éduqué.
Ce pays a, en partie,
protégé ma mère,
qui était d'origine juive,
et qui aurait pu mourir
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale
et qui a été enfant cachée.
Donc ce pays a été,
pour moi, pour nous,
une chance
et il me permet aujourd'hui même
de venir témoigner
dans une émission de télévision,
sur une chaîne parlementaire,
donc sur une chaîne
qui appartient j'allais dire
aux institutions
publiques françaises.
Donc c'est ça que je vois.
J'ai un rapport à la France
qui est extrêmement...
comment dirais-je ?
J'ai une dette envers la France,
pour le dire autrement.
C'est-à-dire
que je lui dois beaucoup.
-Et votre rapport à l'Afrique ?
-L'Afrique, c'est le continent
qui était celui de mon père,
un continent où je vais
de temps en temps,
mais euh...
C'est... J'ai...
Je vais le dire autrement.
En fait, l'Afrique,
ça a été le début
de mon engagement militant.
Mon premier engagement militant,
c'était au lycée Turgot
et on a créé,
avec Léhady Soglo,
qui était le neuveu
de Nicéphore Soglo...
-Qui a été président du Bénin.
-Le fils, pardon, de Nicéphore,
mais le neveu du général Soglo
qui avait été chef d'Etat
dans les années 60,
et Léhady et un certain nombre,
on a créé
un comité afro-antillais
précisément parce que,
dans ce pays, la France,
qui nous donnait beaucoup,
on avait le sentiment qu'il y avait
une toute petite reconnaissance
qui serait nécessaire
de ce que nous étions
et on était très énervés du fait
que tout le monde pensait
pouvoir parler d'Afrique
sans jamais demander
à des gens d'origine africaine.
Mais ça a bien changé.
-Bah oui, la preuve.
-Cet engagement militant, c'est ça.
Et, au fond, l'Afrique,
pour moi, c'est ça,
c'est le moteur d'une solidarité.
-Est-ce que, vous qui êtes
historien, qui enseignez
encore à l'université,
est-ce que,
puisque les rapports
sont aussi étroits
entre l'Afrique francophone,
l'Afrique de l'Ouest, et du Nord,
et la France, est-ce qu'on enseigne
suffisamment, justement,
cette histoire-là,
à l'école, je dirais ?
-A l'école,
je suis pas sûr.
Et ce qui me frappe,
c'est que nous, à l'université,
maintenir les liens est compliqué
parce que plus on prend
des mesures restrictives
sur les visas, sur l'immigration,
plus ça rend compliqué
le parcours de nos étudiants.
Et je me souviens notamment
d'une autre historienne,
Claude-Hélène Perrot,
qui était intervenue
auprès de Chirac pour qu'on ait
des visas étudiants
beaucoup plus légers, faciles,
alors que même montait déjà
tout ce discours
contre les échanges académiques
comme procurant une forme
cachée d'immigration.
Donc je suis très attentif à ça.
A l'école, en fait,
ce qu'on apprend malgré tout,
c'est un peu la géographie.
Il faudrait qu'on apprenne plus
parce que justement
le monde voit ses échanges
certes reculer un peu en volume,
le commerce mondial
est un peu plus faible
que dans les années 2000,
mais la mondialisation reste
un processus très important.
Et donc connaître
les autres continents,
les autres cultures,
je pense que c'est un bénéfice
pour les élèves de France.
-Et la mondialisation est
une chance pour l'Afrique, non ?
-Y a eu deux mondialisations.
-Lesquelles ?
-La première,
qui est celle qui va du 16e siècle
jusqu'à la fin du 19e siècle,
la mondialisation coloniale
et celle-là... voilà.
Et y a la deuxième,
qui commence
à partir des années 80.
-1980.
-Voilà et elle, effectivement...
-C'est de celle-là
"dont" je parlais.
-Celle-là donne l'opportunité
aux Africains d'entreprendre
leur propre développement
et d'essayer de créer une richesse.
C'est important, la richesse,
pas la théorie du ruissellement,
mais si y a pas de riches,
pas d'investissements
car alors l'Etat s'en occupe
et, en général,
il ne voit pas très bien
où sont les besoins.
-Si y avait une figure,
culturelle, ou politique,
ou économique,
qui pour vous symbolise
le continent africain,
ce serait laquelle ?
-Bah moi, j'ai envie
d'en prendre un
qui symbolise...
une certaine forme
de fierté africaine,
dont on a vu la statue
tout à l'heure,
j'ai envie de prendre le roi Ghézo,
parce que c'est un fondateur,
qui met en place des institutions,
qui modernise son pays.
-Quelle période ?
-On est au début du 19e siècle,
et qui ouvre son Etat,
qu'il est en train de constituer,
au commerce avec le monde occidental
et qui va avoir un Etat florissant,
ce qui lui permet de se développer,
ce qui va lui permettre,
pendant un temps,
de faire vivre ce pays,
jusqu'à son petit-fils Béhanzin,
qui, lui, ne saura résister
à la conquête française,
malgré un baroud d'honneur,
et qui finira exilé,
exilé outre-mer.
Voilà, j'aime bien cette dynastie,
elle explique quelque chose
de l'histoire de ce continent.
-Le Bénin dont on disait qu'il était
le quartier latin de l'Afrique.
-Et mes parents se sont connus
au quartier latin.
-Merci, Fabrice D'Almeida.
-Merci.
SOUS-TITRAGE :
RED BEE MEDIA
...